when you go out there and you demand
that everybody praise you and you claim
a new marginalized status you hurt
people who are actually marginalized and
here's the thing there's an empathy bank
for everybody
a lot of people don't like to admit this
but we have a certain bandwidth of
empathy we can't just be
passing out empathy like donuts covered
in skittles
question of the day let me start this
off on a scale from 1 to 10 how much
empathy do you have for the modern day
fat
pride movement and is thin privilege a
thing
uh let me know below because the new
social justice crusade is to expand this
idea of privilege to every possible area
and there was this video uh not too long
ago and they've been expanding upon this
actually
doing more videos but this is the one
that i think is the most egregious
about terrible thin privilege um let's
just
let's go through this piece by piece and
you'll see why i'm so disturbed
thin privilege now it's not a mythical
creature or something made up
if you're thin you have a certain
privilege or
if you're perceived to be thin and
healthy in the eyes of society
you have that privilege what the
everyday tasks that a single person can
take for granted i can leave a
plus-sized person like myself
feel full of anxiety burden and upset
and see things that they don't belong
and don't deserve a place in here
so public transport what unlike me for
plus size people
just think can you sit and see i'm not
being met with signs
puffing up puffing and someone's
swimming in a stick next to you making
you feel uncomfortable okay
first off does thin privilege include
equalizing audio levels what could you
do
could you not just did she just smash
with her greasy fat
palm on the edit keyboard oh my god
you're releasing this out to the world
this is how you're representing yourself
i'm fine i don't know if you should be
talking about fat privilege or a dj with
mouse ears i'm sorry this is so
obnoxious and by the way
perceived as thin what is what is
perceived as thin
this is one thing that people always
they act as though we don't know how to
make these judgments
line up ten people okay make nine of
them
within the bounds of health they don't
have to be all thin they can be somewhat
chubby they can be overweight they can
be on the thin side they can be
right dead center make one of them
really obese
then take 10 people include these other
same 10 people can be obese they can be
thin
i guarantee you every single time they
can go well that's the fat one
it's not perception and by the way on
public transport this is the problem
with this and we'll get back
is is this ends up marginalizing people
who actually are marginalized
when you talk about public transport
this is because
um it literally requires a fundamental
changing of your physical interaction
with the material world
it's not because i hate fat people if
i'm on a plane
if i'm on a train and i sit in a chair
and someone sits uh
sits in the seat next to me right it's
okay i have a seat you have a seat if
this person requires two seats
i need to give them two seats
that's not privileged at all you don't
like sitting next to me on a plane i'm
not fat i'm just a bigger person so if
you take up part of their chair
you gotta get a deal with them aren't
these the same people by the way who
have a problem with man spreading
pretty much i think this is the same you
want to tell me that that is not worse
than man
spreading ah and it was just so much the
way you perceive us the way you treat us
listen if someone has to walk around
you because of the orbit that doesn't
mean that they hate fat people
it means they have to walk around you
because there is physical space they
have to navigate
that wouldn't it wouldn't be the case
with someone who was hidden
within the bounds of you know the bmi
range of
not near immediate death all right let's
move on to our next point here
shop in can you go and save 99.9 for the
high street
shop try on and take an outfit away that
very same day
i don't chop on high street and not
actually been able to go
and enjoy the experience of shopping
nothing like perpetuating the lazy steer
you can't be bothering to do
amazon you can literally shop for
anything at home right now yeah it's a
fat person's world
by the way you know we don't stock
xxxl's at the latter earth credit show
lot of creditshop.com you know why
because we don't sell enough of them
exactly
we have you know this with wine you have
to purchase wholesale and sell retail
it doesn't make sense to purchase
something that would not be profitable
this is the same reason that a general
sporting goods store
might not suck a ton of clothing or
attire
that would be necessary for amputees it
doesn't mean they hate amputees
it means they're not a shop that sells
to a very specific
niche portion of the market that being
said i have far more sympathy for people
who've lost their limbs and more
than people who simply let too many ring
dings get in
look it's the same thing with shoe sizes
right every time i go into a store not 8
9 10 11
12 those sizes are plentiful you can get
anything that you want i have to go to
the very end of the aisle and there's
like eight things to choose from for my
shoe size
right right that's the same thing so
what do i have shoe print like you have
you have privilege if you have a size 12
men's shoe
yeah that's the same thing that you're
saying here of course they're gonna have
stuff that most people can
fit in go to a store there's plenty of
them that have bigger clothes
okay but does the same apply to darba at
nerve socks
i don't know i would assume you can
those are
readily available in land well sizes by
the way
hit the notification bell if you uh
haven't already on youtube actually no
subscribe not only to the channel but
bookmark the page because we're not
necessarily showing up in your feed
subscribe on itunes so you can uh
here's the audio version of course a lot
of career.com if you want to continue
the show all right let's move on to our
next clip it has to do with actual
eating
grabbing something to eat just think can
you pop into a bakery
pick up a doughnut and sit there and
then enjoy it
and not feel like you've met the stays
or comments because
even though i'm confident i can't do
that i've had comments
or being like stared at it's just really
uncomfortable
you just can't enjoy the moment yes so
more comments are coming
i haven't had a donut that size
in years and here's something again the
reason why this criticism
is not designed to be mean-spirited is
you are demanding validation
it's very different no one here would be
like you fat you fat little jerk i want
to
i want to beat you no no one wants to do
that but if you're going out demanding
that the world find you beautiful and
demanding that we turn a blind eye to
all modern medical science uh listen
criticism is entirely valid the lack of
self-awareness here to me is
unbelievable she's eating a doughnut the
size of a pizza pie it looks like
a national geographic special when a
lion gets a hold of a gazelle
except she's literally eating a donut
that has reese's pieces cups on it is it
i know is that what it is can we bring
that up
is that it looks like it how does
something like look this is the thing
that made me look like it was parody why
would you do
that let's break can we bring that up
again that that i was born this way
no listen if you're going to try and
make the case that this is genetic and
it's not your choice
do not pick the pastry the confection
covered in skittles yes sorry let's move
on to the next clip which talks about
the privilege in privilege uh in going
going
and going to the doctor go into the
doctors are you able
to go and be seen and diagnose what is
actually wrong with you
or is the appointment turned into a
weigh-in session
and how you can improve your diet and
lose weight oh you're walking away
or no answers what is actually wrong
with you
and to be honest i actually avoid going
to the doctors now
just because i don't feel like i'm taken
seriously
you can't diagnose health problems by
looking at people actually yes yes you
can
not always no first thing you walk into
a doctor if you say i have something
wrong here they go oh let me take a look
at you yeah
let me take a look at it let me see
what's going on first broken arms third
degree burns
obesity would fall into that category
all easily diagnosable by the eyeball
test
and something else to me is it just me
or every single time that everyone goes
here
to the doctor are you weighed yes yeah
yes this is part of the deal this
this isn't a persecution complex if i
walk in and i've gained eight pounds
over christmas my doctor's like oh
putting on that holiday weight huh
because he's a dick but he's also
accurate
and i appreciate it this is a perfect
example you want to eat donuts covered
in reese's peanut butter cups skittles
whatever it is don't call me on this and
say you need to be fact check there are
reese's pieces which don't actually have
chocolate it's just peanut butter and a
delicious candy shell i don't know what
was on there
the point is it was absurd it was a
novelty item that she includes as a diet
staple
okay and this person is upset that the
primary physician
is remaining consistent with the
mandatory hippocratic oath
in that instead of prescribing you pills
for your lazy gluttonous lifestyle
they want to weigh you and encourage you
to make buy your own admission healthy
dietary choices
this is a great the left always talks
about big farm and how much they want
you to take a pill to feel better
she's literally talking about doctor
shopping and going in looking for a
prescription for an
easily solvable problem much more so
than mental health yeah
no much more so than a lot of other if
if you are significantly overweight you
are obese it should be the doctors
it should be mandatory for a first line
of defense
for the doctor to tell you to stop
eating so many skittles covered donuts i
mean if i were a doctor but i only found
out about the reese's cups covered
donuts and that if i hadn't known that
that was a thing
okay before this last week and i were a
doctor
and someone came in looking looking like
you
uh my first question the question would
be have you been eating donuts covered
in reese's peanut butter cups
[Applause]
it'd be like asking if the dog got into
a choking hazard i'm not comparing you
to a dog but it's the first thing that a
vet usually asks is there something
going on has he been in any weird food
lately i would say oh okay well your bmi
is 94. have you been eating any donuts
slathered in reese's peanut butter cups
and skittles
she goes on with other problems let's
see what else she has to say
if you say that healthier and thinner
people deserve this privilege
because this whole thing actually has
nothing to do
with anybody's health just because
someone's smaller
just in the same way as someone's bigger
there's no way
that you could diagnose someone's heart
just by looking at them
no that's wrong that's wrong against
speaking in these absolutes there's no
this has nothing to do with anybody's
health
okay there are some exceptions but this
has something to do with a lot of
people's health
and by the way even excluding other risk
factors just wait
you have a higher risk of heart disease
stroke heart failure diabetes period
just wait yes i know that bmi is not an
accurate scale i know that i would be
considered seriously overweight because
it's six foot two i'm supposed to like
180 or something like that
i get that that being said i also accept
that when i get older it's better for me
to be thinner regardless of whether
that's muscle fat period your body
doesn't want to carry that much weight
and when it's exclusively fat from
reese's covered donuts
that would that would be considered
excessive and by the way you live in a
country that has a nationalized health
care
plan okay where they have they have a
much higher mortality rate from all
diseases and all risk-related factors in
the united states
and even worse wait times okay so let me
just say
if a private insurer in the united
states can ask me whether i smoke how
what my bmi
is what my i think it's perfectly
acceptable perfectly along the trail of
logic for a
socialized healthcare program to say are
you eating uh donuts covered in skittles
maybe we're going to make an exemption
for diseases related to let me see
yes the donuts covered in skittles
exactly all right anyway but
again the whole point of this is that
this is another form of social
engineering just to make people
feel as though everything that they know
to be true isn't so why
because feelings before you roll your
eyes the idea of think privilege is
try putting yourself in someone else's
shoes and just looking it from their
point of view
how it could affect them or how it could
make them feel well i would try putting
myself in your triple wide shoes but i
don't want to die
it would require years of eating
skittles covered donuts not exercising
sitting on the couch all day and not
going to a doctor okay
that's why i'm not and by the way this
is different than saying hey imagine if
you could put yourself in the shoes of
like
someone who lost their limbs in a war
right arms and a war obviously they
wouldn't have shoes if they lost their
legs and
i don't know sometimes they have shoes
in the nubs i don't know you're good
limbs is good
imagine putting yourself in the shoes i
don't know someone who's autistic
someone with cerebral palsy everyone has
empathy for those people
but we we reserve our empathy and i
would say rightfully so for people
who've been dealt a bad hand
through no fault of their own this woman
you are pos
because you probably see this video we
get a takedown notice every time we do a
fat pride video right it's considered
somehow emotional abuse
you are not amongst them well it's like
having a kid who is out of control and
demands to be praised right listen some
for example if this woman went out there
and i think i i've talked about
sometimes it almost brings a tear to my
eye when i'm at the gym and i see really
overweight people struggling on the
treadmill struggling to lift weights and
i've had friends who've gone to the gym
it was very very hard for them and i
tried to help them along the trail
nobody faults you for that but if you
refuse to do it and then demand that
people praise you
it's like a kid who no one can stand
because they don't want to reward any
behavior because
we're supposed to reward all behavior
and by the way this goes both ways my
wife is naturally very thin
uh she gets a lot of flack for it we've
talked about this she had a complex ring
because people would imply that she had
some kind of eating disorder you've seen
her parents they're all
tall and thin yeah six foot and thin
she's naturally that way i can't tell
you how many women's i've had
uh around herself we only carry sizes
for real women or you need to eat a
sandwich
this happens all the time listen you
don't think that that the only
difference is
she's within the she is thinner or she
was when she was younger right now she
wouldn't know when you looked
when she was younger and she grew up
really quickly she was thinner but she
was well within the bounds of health
and that's something else by the way men
do not expect women to be perfect
just as you don't expect men to be
perfect hopefully women out there don't
expect
all men to have a six-pack that comes
with weeks of dieting down and diuretics
and
getting into a hot tub with winter
greens so you can have veins in your
lower abdomen
we hope you don't expect that just like
we don't expect all of you to look like
a cover model
we do however find ourselves
biologically more attracted to women who
fit within
the good news is a very wide spectrum of
weights
shapes and sizes as long as they are
healthy and
just like all of just like jesse
smallett with fake crimes and poop
swastika
in covington what happens here is when
you go out there and you demand that
everybody praise you and you claim a new
marginalized status you hurt people who
are actually marginalized and here's the
thing there's an empathy bank for
everybody
a lot of people don't like to admit this
but we have a certain bandwidth of
empathy we can't just be passing out
empathy like donuts covered in skittles
so we reserve the right to not give it
to you because we want to give it to the
veteran who had an arm blown off in
vietnam
or we reserve it for somebody who might
have some kind of degenerative brain
disease that can't help it
you ate too many skittles covered donuts
hey there if you like this video
subscribe
or click one of these videos playing in
a box you know what
hit the notification bell because
subscriptions don't really mean anything
anymore
especially if you're not 18 or older at
the very least logged into youtube as 18
or older
because sometimes people are 25 but they
don't know how to use the youtube system
properly and then you never just hit the
notification bell
or you hate yourself